the final volume of stranger things four
is loaded with easter eggs from secret
eggos to fantasy swords stephen king
back to the future and pulp fiction
yippie kai movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm revealing the biggest
best and most epic details hidden in the
second part of season four spoilers
ahead of course so take care the sword
that hopper picks up for his face off
against the demogorgon in russia is no
ordinary weapon it's the legendary
atlantean sword wielded by conan the
barbarian
if you were wondering how on earth the
sword ended up there there's a little
clue in the seventh episode when the
prisoners were given access to a weapons
cabinet just before their fight against
the monster look carefully as dimitri
grabs the spear but one of the others
takes the sword behind him and there was
a tease in the opening episode of season
4 to us getting some conan the barbarian
action later by the poster for the
schwarzenegger movie in mike's bedroom
when hopper and joyce come across a room
in the prison full of demogorgons and
demidogs submerged in giant vats of
liquid the moment has strong echoes of
alien resurrection which co-stars winona
ryder and features her and a cloned
ripley discovering a lab full of tanks
containing various xenomorph experiments
there's also an easter egg to the second
alien movie when sullivan orders his men
to split up and look for eleven squadron
searched by twos hicks ticked up a level
this is a nod to dwayne hicks from
aliens who was also ordered to do the
same thing quarter in search by twos
plus when paul rises owen calls el kiddo
hey kiddo it's a nod to the way his
character burke addresses ripley in
aliens come on that's a second chance
kill on top of that david harbor has
said that the third alien movie was a
big influence for season four and the
way the demo dog chases hop through the
corridors is reminiscent of the
xenomorph chase in alien 3 as well as
bob's fate in season 2. and hopper's
plan to bait one of the demidogs then
lure the others into a trap for murray
to flame them in the prison pit is a
reference to alien 3 where the prisoners
lure the xenomorph into a trap eddie and
his bc rich warlock guitar play a
crucial role in the season finale notice
how the red crackle finish on the guitar
mirrors the upside down's colours with
its red and black and its cracks of
lightning she was destined for an
alternate dimension in fact the classic
heavy metal guitar was customized by the
show's crew from a regular black design
now although the metallica song eddie
plays is actually about drug addiction
its title master of puppets fits how
vechna toys with his victims
manipulating them like their puppets on
a string and many of its lyrics that we
hear during the show tie in well with
the creel house sequence that it
accompanies for example i'm your source
of self-destruction and where's the
dreams i've been after fit how wechner
uses the memories of his victims against
them as he tries to do with max again
here bringing back memories of billy
trapped in the sauna interestingly even
some of the song's lyrics that don't
make it into the show for example
twisting your mind and smashing your
dreams blinded by me you can't see a
thing you're also spot on for max's
story there was also a heartbreaking
clue to eddie's eventual demise at the
hands of the upside downs demo bats
during the d d game in the first episode
because if you look really closely you
can spot a tattoo of bats on his arm
also this tattoo of a clawed hand
controlling a puppet was another clue to
the song master of puppets that eddie
ended up playing in the finale
and just before he dies eddie tells
dustin you're gonna have to look after
those little sheep for me okay a
reference to how he saw the hellfire
club as a place for those like mike and
dustin who didn't fit in i knew at the
moment i saw you sat on that table right
over there looking like tula lost sheep
there's a fantastic visual homage to the
opening scene of star wars when sullivan
and his men storm into the nina facility
the way they blow open the door followed
by a gunfire battle through a
steam-filled corridor is incredibly
reminiscent to the stormtroopers busting
open a doorway and having a shootout
with the rebel guards then the way
sullivan strides down the hallway
looking for l parallels darth vader
arriving in the aftermath of the battle
demanding to know where the death star
plans are
and the duffer brothers have
specifically said they wanted to capture
the tone of the empire strikes back for
season four so there's 11 not wanting to
complete her training with brenna and
instead go and help her friends in
hawkins a reference to how luke
skywalker leaves his training with yoda
early to help leia and han solo plus as
the way the season ends with the
villain's triumph as the upside down
breaks into the real world and one of
our amazing movie lovers points out that
max ending up in a coma brings to mind
han solo being captured and frozen in
carbonite and there's another hat tip to
the galaxy far far away when murray
utters one of the franchise's famous
lines i don't know jim i got a bad
feeling about this as they roll up to
the russian prison to break back in only
to find no gods on watch
after wechner's pain finally releases
the vines that are strangling and about
to kill robin nancy and steve robin
responds i don't believe in a higher
power or a divine intervention that was
a miracle which is a shout out to how
samuel l jackson and john travolta
miraculously survived a hail of bullets
in pulp fiction this was divine
intervention which also starred uma
thurman the mother of robin actress maya
hawk
as nancy is getting the cleaning
supplies together for the gang to clear
up the old cabin in the woods where hop
and elle used to live there's a very
brief shot of a packet of eggos eleven's
favorite food since mike first gave them
to her back in season one whatever you
want kiddo it's on me waffles please
after wekner succeeds in opening the
four gates to the upside down in hawkins
the ground splitting cracks converge in
the middle of town right next to the
clock tower given all the clock
symbolism in season 4 this location
doesn't feel like a coincidence it might
also be a reference to the importance of
the clock tower in back to the future
where it was a crucial way of harnessing
the energy from a lightning strike that
would allow marty to time travel
together with numerous other back to the
future easter eggs in the series i
suspect this moment is yet another
pointer to how time travel will factor
into season 5. something i discuss in a
lot more detail in my how to beat vechna
theory video
when erica strikes back at jason's bully
friend she says
which is a call back to the winning dice
role she made in the dnd game at the
beginning of season four
by the way that d20 role which defeated
wekner in the game will surely also be
significant in how 11 and the gang
eventually defeat the villain
as well as a deliberately rambo-esque
image in the warzone's advert the
store's logo also has a top gun vibe
about it it's an interesting choice
given the tom cruise mentioned this
season you have a tom cruise poster
that's old the post is likely from his
risky business era which released in
1983 the year the first season is set
your lover boy from risky business now
carol thinks i actually kind of look
like him curiously the cruise
comparisons continue this season as
mason dye who plays jason has major tom
cruise vibes and in fact he said he
prepared for the role by watching cruz's
movies and inside the war zone jason and
his fellow jocks have plastered the
place with wanted posters for eddie and
other members of the hellfire club the
war zone scene also reminds me of nancy
and jonathan stocking up on weapons to
do battle with a demogorgon in season 1.
the exploding blood balloons that wekner
sets off when he breaks into max's
memory of the snowball have vibes of the
2002 adaptation of stephen king's novel
carry where she soaked in blood in front
of a balloon arch as well as the it
miniseries where pennywise sets off
blood-filled balloons in front of an
adult ritchie at the library by the way
the scene in volume 1 where 11 is soaked
with a milkshake by angela's bully pals
in front of everyone at the rink is
another reference to carrie getting
soaked in pig's blood and laughed at by
her peers as an event that triggers her
powers
along with nightmare on elm street and
it another huge horror influence on both
parts of season 4 is clive barker's hell
raiser wekner's attic in the creel house
where he goes for his creepy meditation
sessions has big hellraiser vibes as
julia takes frank's victims there to
feed upon and the rose window in the
door of the creel house is also a
reference to the stained glass window in
the door of the hellraiser house the
duffer brothers have also said that
vechna is inspired by pinhead from the
hellraiser movies and despite their
quite different appearances both
antagonists have a similar origin in
that they were both once human before
transforming into villains that
primarily inhabit an extra-dimensional
realm
the michael myers mask that eddie puts
on when the crew steal the rv is the
same one that max wore for halloween
night in season two brett uh you got a
ski mask or a bandana or something like
that there's also a big halloween and
michael myers easter egg and the way
wechner's body disappears after he falls
through the creel house attic window and
i explained that together with even more
easter eggs from the finale such as the
stephen king book that lucas reads to
max in my volume 2 ending explained in
season 5 theories video you can tap here
to watch that or follow the link in the
video description
so movie lovers what other cool details
or references did you spot in the second
part of season four let me know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video do hit that like button i really
appreciate it you can also tap left to
discover why i think 11 will be time
traveling in season 5 in order to defeat
wekner thanks for enjoying stranger
things with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie loving week yippie kai
movie lovers